bonjour je suis Genola bigouin la
directrice de l'espace Alphonse d'udé à
coanière aujourd'hui je vais vous
conseiller un
[Musique]
spectacle première bonne raison de voir
le spectacle c'est que c'est un
spectacle participatif le public choisit
l'une des réponses
[Musique]
chorégraphiques
c'est que ça devrait être les gens qui
utilisent qui l'utilisent bien une
deuxième raison donc c'est une cette
démarche originale permet finalement de
démocratiser la danse contemporaine et
la troisième raison donc c'est cette
démarche originale finalement elle
permet aussi de de briser le mur
habituel entre le public et les danseurs
ce qui fait que les spectateurs sont
acteurs de ce qui se passe sur le le
plateau ils vivent réellement les
interrogations sur la rencontre la à
l'utre et
[Musique]
l'émancipation voici les trois bonnes
raisons d'assister à ce spectacle le
spectacle entre de la compagnie
pointvgule qui aura lieu le 16 décembre
à 19h à l'Espace Alfonse
d'Hel